d'état il s'agit de la fonction publique
d'état de la fonction publique
territoriale discuter de la fonction
publique hostile hospitalière on a
recours un recours massif aux
contractuels et pourquoi parce que les
rencontres actuel ça se met à la porte
donc le contractuel se soumet un à son
administration
mais pourtant valérie bertel lorieux il
n'y a pas si longtemps que ça on entendu
emmanuel macron le président de la
république qui était l'un devant la
presse devant les français pour répondre
à la crise des gilets jaunes il avait
promis plus de services publics plus de
proximité plus de pouvoir de décision
pour les élus locaux comme les autres et
puis l'avait évoqué effectivement ses
fonctionnaires en disant qu'il serait là
il aurait plus de plus de missions plus
de responsabilités alors entre le
discours est ce qui se fait sur le
terrain en général il y a un écart qui
est de plus en plus grand sur le terrain
moi je vois des collègues devant leurs
salles qui sont en train de travailler
face à des élèves rappelle que vous êtes
syndicaliste dans l'éducation nationale
oui je suis dans l'éducation nationale
il ya des collègues qui travaillent au
quotidien et qui donne tout pour leurs
élèves
aujourd'hui ils ont un statut certes
mais le statut est créé pour ça pour que
le service public soit donnée de manière
égale à des citoyens
c'est ça que ça a sur le service public
et le fonctionnariat aujourd'hui on nous
dit par exemple au rectorat tous les
jours un coeur il y à une baisse
d'élèves du nombre d'élèves par classe
je leur dirai ça c'est au feu c est une
réalité il ya une baisse d'élèves mais
parallèlement il ya il ya quelque chose
que l'on ne dit pas le rectorat et bien
dans l'incapacité de remplacer un
certain nombre de collègues qui sont
malades par exemple parce que c'est vrai
c'est vrai que souvent nous recevons des
coups de fils par exemple de parents se
plaignant de baies de professeurs
absents depuis plusieurs semaines
plusieurs mois
je sors d'un établissement scolaire j'ai
vu j'ai été dans un établissement
scolaire cette semaine et qu'est ce qui
s'est passé à bien tout simplement j'ai
rencontré les collègues qui me disent
qu'il ya des profs d'anglais qui ne sont
pas remplacés depuis trois mois
tout simplement parce que le rectorat ne
peut pas remplacer des produits des
profs d'anglais ni des prof d'espagnol
ni les profs d'histoire-géo ni des profs
de philo devant des élèves
il ya un vrai projet d'ensemble
pénurie de ce type de deux professeurs
il ya un problème de viviez et en plus
ce dernier ne fait plus rêver
il y à déjà le problème du fait que le
métier ne fasse plus rêver mais en plus
derrière le rectorat est dans
l'incapacité de les remplacer on veut
mettre en place des contractuels
derrière pour remplacer les postes que
l'on supprime je rappelle quand même que
sucette dix dernières années il ya mille
postes d'enseignants qui ont été
supprimés parallèlement on embauche des
contractuels quand on est en mesure de
le faire le rectorat est obligé d'aller
voir pôle emploi aujourd'hui pour
chercher des profs d'histoire-géo accès
dont des matières que je viens de vous
citer terminée voilà et qu'on rend on
est en train de remplacer les
fonctionnaires par des contractuels et
c'est extrêmement grave parce qu'ils
peuvent être soumis à des pressions de
tous types type de pression peut avoir
lorsqu'on est par exemple contractuelle
dans l'éducation nationale qu'ont été
recrutés via pour l'emploi pour venir
dispenser quelques cours d'anglais ou
d'espagnol à des élèves de vince il
suffit tout simplement de ne pas
appliquer stricto sensu ce que vous dit
votre hiérarchie qui peuvent être vos
trois hiérarchie dans votre
établissement ou de votre hiérarchie
votre inspecteurs et qu'on vous dise
tout simplement
demain tu seras à la porte parce que tu
n'applique pas stricto sensu ce que je
veux et puis il ya un exemple aussi qui
est extraordinaire mais qui est d'une
tristesse grave quand on voit le premier
article de la loi bancaire
la loi du ministre de l'éducation
nationale qui demande aux enseignants de
se taire qui parle de devoir de réserve
c'est quand même la première fois que
l'on voit ça qui parle d'un devoir de
réserve on n'est pas des médecins on est
des enseignants et quand on voit
et quand on met tout ça en parallèle on
se dit que c'est un projet de société et
ce projet de société ne correspond pas à
ce que ce voeu le snes pour la société
française et plus particulièrement pour
la société martiniquaise
alors au delà de tout cela la terre
syndicales qui appellent aujourd'hui à
cette grève unitaire estime que le
pouvoir exécutif poursuit une politique
contraire aux intérêts de la population
vous venez de l'audience concerne
l'éducation et ça ça se vérifie
également dans la fonction publique
territoriale la fonction publique
hospitalière alors je pourrais parler
essentiellement de la fonction publique
d'état puisque c'est celle que je
connais mieux
bien évidemment les intérêts sont
contraire quand on regarde la réforme du
lycée la réforme du bac
naturellement que les intérêts sur
contraire on ne permet pas aux élèves de
choisir des filières comme ça l'était
avant on met en place une d'aider des
filières noble 1
d'ailleurs on s'est rendu compte qu'au
niveau national il y avait les chiffres
sont tombés la semaine dernière mais ça
se vérifie aussi dans les établissements
scolaires en martinique que 71 % des
élèves choisissent les mathématiques
quand on sait aussi que les programmes
des mathématiques seront extrêmement
difficiles
beaucoup d'élèves vont abandonner les
mathématiques et puis derrière il ya
parcours sup
en fait on se rend compte que tout est
en train de s'imbriquer et que ce projet
de société qui est décidée par l'état ne
correspond pas à ce que l'on attend pour
notre jeunesse nous voulons d'une
jeunesse bien formée
je donne aussi un petit exemple il ya
les projets le projet de la réforme du
bac
et quand on se rend compte de ce qu'on
va demander à des élèves de terminale en
histoire géo
on est vraiment dans un projet comme le
brevet c'est l'épreuve qui sera proposé
aux élèves est une épreuve de brevet et
plus de bacs
donc les enfants dont les familles
seront socialement beaucoup plus élevés
auront davantage de chances qu'on
nivelle par une nouvelle barre le bar
exactement on nivelle par le bas
et puis on ne donne pas la chance à tout
le monde d'accéder aux mêmes choses
le premier des dix c'est un des points
de revendication de la terre syndicales
au point de 10 qui ne bouge pas ou qui
évolue trop trop trop trop trop peu avec
de tels argumentation on rappelle la
suppression de postes double langage du
gouvernement politique contraire aux
intérêts de la population plus ce point
des dix théoriquement aujourd'hui tout à
l'heure à la maison des syndicats
devraient avoir énormément de
fonctionnaires pour protester contre
cette politique gouvernementale nous
espérons profondément que les collègues
vont venir tout à l'heure à 8h30 à la
maison des syndicats et qu'on pourra
faire une manifestation massive
vous savez nous passons quotidiennement
presque dans les établissements
scolaires nous voyons tous les collègues
les collègues sont persuadés du
fondement de notre discours et sont
persuadés que le gouvernement va dans le
mauvais sens cependant aujourd'hui c'est
vrai que les collègues aussi des les
obligations des obligations notamment
pécuniaire des enfants qui font des
études etc
ce sont des arguments quand
on entend vu que justement le point des
dix n'augmentent pas comment comprendre
comment expliquer que les vos collègues
ne se manifeste pas davantage vous
demandez pourtant une discussion avec le
gouvernement qui est quand même montré
du doigt accusés par la terre syndicales
de ne pas pratiquer les parcs il manque
bien la question du dialogue a bien
évidemment on le voit aussi au niveau du
rectorat il ya un vrai problème de
dialogue social on nous écoute mais on
s'assied sur les décisions que l'on
prend on fait semblant de libérer la
parole on fait semblant brive libérer la
parole on fait semblant donner des
droits et puis à partir du moment où il
y à un vote qui va dans le sens
contraire de ce que l'administration
veut puisque aujourd'hui on le recteur
on a la possibilité il s'assied sur le
vote qui est effectué par l'ensemble des
organisations syndicales le dialogue
social n'existe pas mais en même temps
c'est vrai que les collègues ont du mal
et des fois ils nous disent oui qu'ils
auraient préféré faire une grève longue
qui dure mais en même temps il ya aussi
la question de pouvoir d'achat derrière
ce n'est pas si facile que ça à mettre
en oeuvre mais pour l'instant nous
sommes persuadé du bien fondé de notre
lutin et qu'il faille aujourd'hui
manifester parce que c'est aussi le
dialogue du le discours du ministre
oui parce que lorsqu'on regarde votre
plateforme de revendications vous parlez
de propositions de propositions
alternatives mais s'il n'y a pas de
dialogue comment les faire entendre ses
propositions alternatives
parce qu en fait le corps le
gouvernement demande aux organisations
syndicales de venir négocier une
législation qu'il met en place le texte
il est déjà entièrement faits et la
possibilité de négociation est infime et
il y à certaines choses qu'on ait réussi
à obtenir mais pour la plupart du temps
qu'est ce qu'il dit de toutes les façons
c'est mon texte qui sera voté
et puis on connaît le fonctionnement de
cette de cette constitution
ils sont ultra majoritaires à
l'assemblée nationale donc naturellement
il peut faire passer ce qu'ils veulent
donc il n'y a pas vraiment de dialogue
sincère d'appeler à la grève unitaire
parce que nous sommes aussi conscients
de ce que c'est ce qui est en train de
se faire en france avec les gilet jaune
ne donnant les phases de chèque en blanc
donc voilà il n'est pas question de
donner de chèque en blanc mais la rue la
rue a un sens et la rue sera regardée
précisément aujourd'hui jeudi jeudi 9 la
rue sera regardé et c'est important que
chacun des collègues se sentent
conscient que les enjeux sont
extrêmement grand il s'agit pas d'un
enjeu de 30e j'aurai une journée en
moins sur mon salaire
les enjeux sont beaucoup plus plus grand
essai derrière c'est notre jeunesse ce
sont nos enfants aussi pour lesquelles
on se bat merci valérie vais enfin
loriot rappelle que vous êtes co
secrétaire académique du snes martinique
et que vous êtes composantes de cette
intersyndicale qui appellent à la grève
et que votre rendez vous c'est tout à
l'heure dans un peu plus d'une heure à
la maison des syndicats forts de france
merci d'avoir été avec nous ce matin
dans son caddie bonne journée merci
mauricienne
[Musique]